RESERVES.
>> OKAY.
>> FROM THE WESTERN CONFERENCE.
DRAYMOND, I HEARD YOU SAY THE
NAME.
I AM WITH YOU.
WE TALKED ABOUT LAST WEEK WHO WE
WANTED TO SEE IN HERE AND THE
CONSIDERATION WE WERE HOPING, I
WAS HOPING DEJOUNTE MURRAY WOULD
GET IN.
HE IS HAVING AN UNBELIEVABLE
YEAR WITH THE SPURS WHO
RECORD-WISE STRUGGLED.
>> I EXPECTED THEIR RECORD TO BE
WORSE THAN WHAT IT ACTUALLY IS.
IT HASN'T BEEN THAT IN LARGE
PART DUE TO DEJOUNTE'S PLAY.
HE HAS CONTINUED TO GROW EVERY
YEAR.
A KID WITH AN ACL INJURY,
REHABBED AND CAME BACK STRONGER.
IF YOU FOLLOW HIM AT ALL, THE
KID LIVES IN THE GYM.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL BE REWARDED
ONE OF THESE DAYS SOON.
I THINK HE MAY HAVE A CHANCE TO
BE REWARDED BECAUSE I WON'T BE
ABLE TO PLAY IN THE ALL-STAR
GAME AND HE MAY HAVE A CHANCE TO
BE REWARDED BY COMMISSIONER
SILVER.
>> 20 POINTS A NIGHT.
EIGHT REBOUNDS.
NINE ASSISTS.
FOURTH IN THE LEAGUE IN ASSISTS.
HE HAS TEN TRIPLE-DOUBLES AND IS
THE LEAGUE LEADER IN STEALS.
YOU MAKE AN EXCELLENT POINT
DRAYMOND AND THANK YOU FOR THE
INSIGHT INTO WHEN YOU MAY BE
COMING BACK.
I KNOW IT WILL BE AFTER THE
ALL-STAR BREAK.
>> ALSO, ANOTHER GUY THAT WILL
BE UNDER HEAVY CONSIDERATION IS
JAREN JACKSON.
>> WITH THE GRIZZ.
>> MEMPHIS GRIZZLIES ARE ON A
TEAR.
HE IS PLAYING GREAT BASKETBALL.
YOU KNOW JA MORANT IS OBVIOUSLY
PLAYING MVP CALIBER.
BUT THAT TEAM WHEN HE WAS
OUTPLAYED JUST AS WELL AT TIMES.
JUSTIN JACKSON.
>> YEAH.
WHEN WE PICKED OUR RESERVES LAST
WEEK, I HAD JUSTIN JACKSON ON
THE LIST.
HE HAS BEEN FABULOUS ALL YEAR.
OBVIOUSLY JA IS THE MAN BUT
JACKSON I THINK HE IS THE REALLY
NICE NUMBER TWO.
>> THIS IS THE UNFORTUNATE PART
OF THE BUSINESS.
YOU CAN ONLY PICK SEVEN
RESERVES.
EVERY YEAR THERE WILL ALWAYS BE
SOMEONE VERY, VERY CLOSE TO
GETTING IN.
WISH THEM WELL FOR NEXT YEAR.
>> DO WE HAVE A LOOK AT THE GUYS
THAT WE THOUGHT WOULD BE
RESERVES IN THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE FROM LAST WEEK AND WE
WILL SEE HOW WE DID IN THIS.
YOU AND I BOTH HAD KARL-ANTHONY
TOWNS.
DID WE RUN THE TABLE ON THAT?
SHAQ AND MYSELF?
>> YOU ALWAYS DO, BROTHER.
SINCE 1989 BROTHER.
>> I WOULDN'T BE MAD TO SEE THE
SPARTAN DOG TO GET IN THERE.
I WOULD NOT BE MAD AT THAT AT
ALL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO THOSE SEVEN --
>> DRAYMOND, IN YOUR DAYS OF
THIS, WHO HAVE YOU SEEN TAKING
THIS THE HARDEST WHEN THEY DID
NOT MAKE IT?
>> ONE THING I CAN ASSURE YOU IF
I DIDN'T MAKE IT THIS YEAR I
WASN'T GOING TO CRY.
IT HAS TO BE RUDY.
THE MAN CRIED ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION WHEN HE DIDN'T MAKE
THE ALL-STAR TEAM.
THANK GOD HE MADE THE LAST
THREE.
YOU CAN'T CRY.
>> YOU RIGHT.
>> COME ON, HE IS FRENCH.
HE IS SENSITIVE.
>> THAT IS OKAY.
>> HE IS A LOVER, MAN.
>> WE WILL SEE A COUPLE OF
THOSE --
>> NO MEAN STREAKS IN PARIS.
>> WE WILL SEE A COUPLE OF THOSE
ALL-STAR RESERVES RECEIPTING THE
PHOENIX SUNS IN GAME ONE OF THE
DOUBLE-HEADER.
CHRIS PAUL